انهم يشكلون خطرا اكبر اليوم مقارنه بقبل
سته اشهر ونحن ناخذ هذا على محمل الجد
تستمر الولايات المتحده في شن غاراتها ضد
داعش وتراقب احتماليه قدوم الجيل الجديد
من مقاتل المنظمه من اراضي الولايات
المتحده هذه مشكله في عده دول ونحن
نواجهها هنا في امريكا يحبين السلطات تحقق
في امكانيه كون صوت الرجل المسموع في
فيديو فولي يعود لمواطن امريكي لكن
المشكله التي تواجهها السلطات الان هي
تعقب المواطنين الذين قد يكونون على
ارتباط بمجموعات ارهابيه وتجند داعش فعلا
الجيل الجديد من المسلحين في الولايات
المتحده باستخدام مقاطع دعائيه والتقنيات
الجديده تؤدي الى تحديات جديده كذلك لا
يوجد لدينا شرطه سياسيه في هذه الدوله لذا
فان مكتبه تحقيقات الفيدرالي لا يمكنه
السعي وراء الاشخاص في فيسبوك وطرق
الابواب عليهم ببساطه لانهم مشتبهم جهود
داعش للتجنيد استخدمت فعلا بعد الامريكيين
نتعقب مئه امريكي يقاتلون مع داعش الان
واصدر مكتب التحقيقات تحذيرات للجهات
الامنيه بخطوره داعش وجهودها بحسد الدعم
من خلال وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وتم
التحقيق مع امريكيين بالفعل عن روابطه
محتمله بمجموعات اسلاميه متشدده اذ تم
توقيف رجل في اغسطس اب الحالي بمطار
امريكي لامتلاكه مسدسا وتم استجوابه بشكل
مطول بسبب تغريدات دعم فيها داعش كما
اعتقلت سيده من كولورادو في ابريل الانسان
الماضي لتامرها بتوفير دعم مادي لارهابي
لذا فان البحث عن اي نشاطات وتغريدات
ومعلومات سفر مشبوهه قد يقود المحققين الى
المخاطر المحتمله التي تهدد الولايات
المتحده